[Musique]
personne est occupée par les russes
depuis le 2 mars mais les habitants
continuent à résister et à protester
défiant carrément les soldats mais
l'étau se resserre et ce qu'ils peuvent
dans de fuir
c'est le cas de salva bo un jeune
comédien qui vient tout juste d'arriver
à kiev pas facile il faut contourner les
zones de combat un voyage infernal car
sonic offre au tac à 10 pernod ricard
les innombrables contrôles sont sévères
parfois il faut graisser la patte des
officiers russes pour passer cela va et
comédien dans un spectacle comique il
fait des blagues sur poutine et les
soldats russes il valait donc mieux
partir comme c'est le cas d'anastasia
qui veut taire son nom parce que ses
parents sont restés là bas et n'ont
commencé à
questionner qui vous aide est ce que
vous êtes journaliste
puis ils regardent et d'une écrivaine
quelque chose comme favori ça veut dire
vivre de crème corps nu et dit pourquoi
tu décris est ce que tu es nazis
comme cela va anastasia le russe comme
langue maternelle mais elle se sent
ukrainienne d'importants inconnu
très vite les russes ont coupé toute
communication avec l'ukraine la
population s'est retrouvé en situation
de pénurie à faire la queue pour tout
comme à l'époque soviétique très peu
d'image en plus sortir de personnes
celles des manifestations ont
impressionné le monde entier
au début il y avait des manifestations
tous les jours dit cela va puis c'est
devenu trop dangereux l'armée a été
remplacé par la milice et la répression
est devenue violente pas ton cas
je sentirai beaucoup beaucoup de
pression
au début de la guerre j'ai même changé
j'ai commencé à parler prégnant parce
qu'avant je parle est revenu mais après
qu'ils sont arrivés à ma maison j'avais
très peur j'ai recommencé à parler russe
parce que c est vraiment dangereux tu
sais jamais ce qui se passe dans nos
bacs les russes traque les activistes
les vétérans de l'armée ukrainienne il
cherche ce qu'ils appellent les nazis
inspectent les tatouages il ya beaucoup
d'optimisme et des politiciens il ya des
journalistes qui sont disparus garçons
et on sait pas où ils sont soit qu'ils
sont déportées soit qu'ils sont
questionnés dans quelques prisons ou
même tué lors à kiev cela va te donne
des spectacles comiques pour lever des
fonds pour l'armée ukrainienne
anastasia est arrivé à odessa il ya deux
jours quand j'ai vu la résistance armée
collègues et amis mais ça maintenant je
sens très en sécurité ici à mon dessin
en comparant avec carson nikolaïev sur
la route obligé vers odessa résiste à
partir de personnes les russes veulent
absolument la capturer car elle est la
clé de la conquête du port d'odessa au
sud sur les bords de la mer noire le
joyau est le poumon économique dont
l'ukraine ne peut pas se passer jean
michel leprince est du canada kiev